Dr. Bright, Dr. Clef, and Dr. Gears all sat
around a conference table, the monitor beside
them giving a direct encrypted video link
to O5-1, the most senior member of the legendary
O5 Council.
Only one topic was on the roster today: The
inherent nature of one of their most problematic
anomalies, SCP-682, the Hard to Destroy Reptile.
There were certain facts that were easy to
ascertain about SCP-682, like the fact that
its default state appears to be vaguely reptilian,
the fact that it’s highly aggressive, and
the fact that it is seemingly impossible to
kill.
The rest, it seems, is still largely shrouded
in mystery.
“How can we expect to terminate this creature
if we don’t fully resolve to understand
it?”
Dr. Gears offered.
“It appears that all of our efforts so far
have amounted to firing a gun in the dark
and hoping for the best.
Do you all have any idea how much money we’ve
blown on the termination effort so far?
Believe me, the numbers would shock you.”
Dr. Bright chimed in with, “As the only
one in this room who’s literally been inside
this monster’s head” - referring to the
incident wherein SCP-682 was made to ingest
Dr. Bright’s medallion in hopes of letting
the Doctor’s consciousness take over the
beast, which didn’t work - “I think I
speak with a degree of authority when I say
I’m not sure if we’d have any luck actually
understanding it.
It’s like asking a volcano how it feels
about erupting.”
Dr. Clef’s thoughts on the matter were predictable.
“Okay, look, I may not have mind-melded
with this abomination like Jack, but I’ve
got two working eyes and a decent brain attached
to them.
That’s all I need to tell you our solution
here is obvious: More firepower.
We’ve been going easy on this thing so far,
letting it face different anomalies one at
a time, not going at it with any truly heavy
weaponry, and for some stupid reason, ruling
out nuclear armaments—“
That had everyone around the room rolling
their eyes.
“There he goes with the nukes again,”
Dr. Bright said.
“Nukes, nukes, nukes.
If you love nukes so much, why don’t you
marry them, eh, Clef?”
Clef grumbled in frustration.
“When did everyone around here get so risk-averse?
Faint heart never won fair maid, or killed
giant ugly lizards!
Why should we treat nuke like it’s such
a dirty word?”
Dr. Gears sighed.
“If the break room coffee machine malfunctioned,
you’d tell us to make sure the nuclear response
option stays on the table, Clef.”
Clef banged his hand on the table.
“Because I believe in getting results, no
matter what!”
“ENOUGH!”
O5-1 barked, silencing the room.
Everyone turned to the monitor and gave their
undivided attention as their superior spoke.
“I can staunchly confirm that we will not
be pursuing a nuclear option for 682 under
any circumstances.
I don’t intend on creating a Godzilla we
need to fight.
Gears, I think you’re on to something.
We’ve done all we can to analyze SCP-682
through the eyes of scientific empiricist,
perhaps we need to look at it through the
eyes of its fellow anomalies - The ones that
aren’t completely insane, anyway.
Make it happen, gentlemen.
Chop chop.”
And so they did.
All three of the incredibly different doctors
did see the wisdom in O5-1’s new theory:
Perhaps they could gain a more holistic understanding
of SCP-682 by collating knowledge gained from
other anomalies.
And through this knowledge, they might also
be able to find a weakness that somehow slipped
by unnoticed.
Right now, SCP-682 was like an impenetrable
locked door.
But even the most durable locked door can
be defeated with the right key.
There were certain anomalous perspectives
on SCP-682 that they already had.
Take, for example, that of SCP-343, the kindly
reality warper also known as God.
When confronted with SCP-682 during a termination
attempt, the two of them seemed patently unaware
of each other’s presence.
When quizzed on the subject, 343 claimed that
682 wasn’t one of his, perhaps implying
some kind of extradimensional origin.
It also lends credence to the popular theory
that SCP-682 is one of the children of the
Scarlet King, though for now, that would still
remain nothing more than a theory, not something
they could really act upon.
This was why each of the three researchers,
following the orders from O5-1, began canvasing
reactions from other intelligent anomalies,
in hopes of getting a useful kernel of information
from a fresh new angle.
Dr. Bright, who has frankly seen far too many
movies, thought of himself as Clarice Starling,
interviewing a whole collection of Hannibal
Lecters in hopes of gaining a unique insight
that would help him catch the killer.
When he shared this thought with Dr. Clef
and Dr. Gears, Gears told Bright that he didn’t
watch movies, and Clef called Bright a nerd.
After the proper safety precautions were put
in to make sure that the two never actually
came into physical or mental contact, Dr.
Clef had SCP-035 - the devious, diabolical
Possessive Mask - attached to a mannequin
host body and brought in to observe SCP-682
in a sealed chamber.
Clef asked the Possessive Mask to relay any
thoughts he had while looking at the beast.
Admittedly, Dr. Clef felt a little unnerved
by how gleeful the Mask looked while watching
the Hard to Destroy Reptile clambering around
its tank.
“Oh yes, yes,” the Possessive Mask said,
its words like cyanide in the ears.
“What a truly marvelous creature.
So large, so powerful, so violent.
I can feel the hatred radiating off of it
from here.
You know, the hateful ones are often the easiest
to manipulate.
There’s so much they’ll do for power,
so much they’ll sign away, while their malice
blinds them.
Oh, delightful.
Such a wonderful thought.
I don’t suppose you’d let him wear me,
would you?”
Dr. Clef shook his head.
“Not on your life, creep.”
Sadly, it didn’t seem as though any new
insights had really been gained here.
Hopefully, Dr. Gears would have a little more
luck with his project.
Dr. Gears had decided to take a more measured
approach - unsurprising, given this is Dr.
Gears we’re talking about - and went for
an intelligent anomaly who probably wasn’t
harboring some evil ulterior motive: SCP-507,
the Reluctant Dimension Hopper.
Two things highly benefited Dr. Gears in this
regard.
Firstly, the Reluctant Dimension Hopper had
gotten around and seen more things than pretty
much any other mortal being in existence.
Secondly, SCP-507 had certain aspirations
- Namely, to become an SCP Foundation researcher,
where he could be accepted and make a profession
out of his interest in the supernatural.
Gears could leverage this to gain cooperation.
When SCP-507 was brought in to observe 682,
Gears noticed a certain flicker of recognition
in the Dimension Hopper’s eyes, before the
man opened his mouth and said, “Oh god,
not another one of those things.”
Gears immediately fired back.
“Another one, you say?”
SCP-507 nodded.
“Yeah, during one of my jumps, I was in
this big, weird landscape covered in freaky-looking
rocks.
There were a whole bunch of these guys there,
like a herd or a pack or something.
As soon as they saw me, they started chasing
me.
It was honestly pretty tense, for a second
there, I didn’t even know if I’d make
it out alive.”
Dr. Gears nodded and continued taking notes.
“Do you have any further observations from
your time seeing these creatures in another
dimension?”
SCP-507 shook his head, presumably disappointed
that he couldn’t offer more.
“Thank you, that will be all then, 507,”
Dr. Gears said.
And, of course, that left one more.
The maverick.
The joker in the pack.
Dr. Jack Bright, the man from whom you can
only ever really expect the unexpected.
He’d decided to take the middle ground between
the offerings of Dr. Gears and Dr. Clef: SCP-049,
the Plague Doctor, the mysterious being who
can kill with a touch, but has aspirations
to heal.
Dr. Bright was extremely interested in seeing
what he had to say about the nasty reptile.
That same day, the Plague Doctor was feeling
a little irritated, to say the least.
He’d been conducting some extremely important
research into the Pestilence on a cow carcass
when suddenly, an order from the top deemed
he would no longer have access to animal subjects.
Lavender had been pumped into his cell to
pacify him while five heavily-armored guards
entered and dragged out his latest subjects.
It was cruel, it was inhumane, it was anti-science!
First, they’d taken away his live human
subjects.
Then, they’d taken away his dead human subjects,
followed by his live animal subjects.
If he wasn’t even allowed to perform his
vital research on animal carcasses now, then
what hope did he have of making progress?
While out there in the world, every single
day, the Pestilence spreads further.
Who even knows what form it has taken on now?
After all, diseases shift and mutate with
the times, and the whole world was a Petri
dish out there.
As the Plague Doctor was lost in his musings,
Dr. Bright approached and rapped his knuckles
on the plexiglass of his containment chamber.
“Leave me be, Doctor,” the Plague Doctor
sighed.
“Haven’t you and your compatriots already
taken enough from me?”
“I’m not here to take, Doctor, I’m here
to give,” Dr. Bright said.
“I know we can be a little harsh in our
measures sometimes, Doc, but we’re cold,
not cruel.
You play ball with us, you’ll find we can
be very amicable.
To the tune of, say, getting your live animal
research privileges back?”
There was a moment of silence, before the
Plague Doctor rose up and walked over to the
divider between himself and Dr. Bright.
He cocked his head slightly, as though taking
in Dr. Bright’s measure.
“What would you have me do in return, Doctor?”
the Plague Doctor asked.
Dr. Bright smiled.
“There’s just something I want you to
look at.”
With the assistance of a few security officers,
the Plague Doctor was moved over to an observation
chamber, joining onto a larger, more secure
chamber.
The Plague Doctor sat on a plush chair, staring
through a one-way mirror into the larger chamber.
Dr. Bright turned on a dictaphone, hoping
to record any interesting observations the
Plague Doctor came out with.
“What, pray tell, am I supposed to be looking
at, Dr. Bright?” he asked.
“They’re bringing him in now.
Won’t be a moment,” Dr. Bright said.
A large door in the larger chamber opened,
and several members of personnel dragged in
a tied-up, incapacitated SCP-682, looking
like it was still recovering from heavy injuries.
Immediately, SCP-049 seemed to tense up.
Dr. Bright was fascinated, watching the Plague
Doctor’s previously calm demeanor suddenly
become marred by clearly evident worry.
What was he thinking?
Would it be a useful insight?
The silence continued as the Plague Doctor
seemed to carefully observe the immobilized
beast.
For a moment or two, Dr. Bright even noticed
the Plague Doctor’s hands shaking slightly.
Moments later, the Doctor cleared his throat
and said, “The Pestilence!
Never have I seen it so malignant!”
“Come again, Doc?”
Dr. Bright asked.
“This...
Thing.
It is sick, Doctor, dreadfully sick.
It is a bastion of disease, a harbinger of
Plague, unlike anything that has ever been
seen before.
How long have you had this filthy thing within
your walls, Doctor?
How many people have made contact with it?
Quickly, please!
I must know, for the safety of all of you!”
As the Plague Doctor became increasingly agitated,
Dr. Bright became a mix of deeply concerned
and incredibly curious.
Sure, SCP-049 tended to go off about a lot
of things allegedly being infected with “The
Pestilence”, but this is different.
There is genuine fear shaking in the Plague
Doctor’s voice.
“I feel unwell, Doctor,” the Plague Doctor
said, rising shakily to his feet.
“Please, escort me back to my chambers.
I simply cannot deal with such a case without
proper preparations.
It would be too dangerous.”
Dr. Bright ordered the security personnel
to make the Plague Doctor’s desire a reality.
He would be escorted back to his chamber,
be given a lavender supplement, as well as
a meal of beef and hard cheese - his favorite-
to help him recuperate from his shock.
But all throughout this process, Dr. Bright
had latched on to one fragment of the Doctor’s
mutterings.
“I simply cannot deal with such a case without
proper preparations.”
Did that mean, with the proper preparations,
SCP-049 could deal with SCP-682?
And as with most of 049’s “patients”,
did “deal” mean “kill?”
If so, then this project was really about
to bear some impressive fruit.
After giving the Plague Doctor a few days
to get himself reoriented, Dr. Bright returned
with another offer - One he wasn’t even
sure he had the authorization to make, but
if his plan worked out, he was sure he could
swing it.
He offered the Plague Doctor the chance to
work with human subjects again...
If he could first successfully treat SCP-682.
“It would certainly be an undertaking,”
SCP-049 said, trying to hide his clear discomfort.
“But for the sake of science, I must accept.”
Over the next few days, the preparations were
drafted up, and the Plague Doctor was given
any equipment or resources he requested for
the task of “curing” SCP-682.
Then, when the day came, SCP-682 was tied
up and sedated once again, and dragged into
a large cross-testing chamber where Dr. Bright,
the Plague Doctor, and several members of
security personnel were waiting.
It was now or never.
Would the Doctor be able to do it?
“For what it’s worth, I believe in you,
Doc,” Dr. Bright said, giving a tentative
thumbs up.
The Plague Doctor didn’t return the thumbs
up - he was too busy trying to stop himself
from visibly shaking in the face of this giant,
diseased monstrosity.
Would he have any hope of treating such a
beast?
He exhaled and approached.
As with all of his patients, his first step
would be to lay a hand on the monster, which
normally rendered it peaceful and still.
The Plague Doctor slowly walked over, his
hand extended, feeling the prickles of fear
all over his body.
He could do this...
But as he approached, SCP-682 had somehow
freed one of its arms, and swung for SCP-682
with its vicious claws.
049 screamed and stumbled back, hitting the
ground and crawling away in the opposite direction,
practically wheezing with terror.
He eventually gathered himself up into the
corner and curled into a ball, shaking.
Dr. Bright breathed a sigh of disappointment,
it seemed this entire venture had been a wash.
”Take 049 back to his cell,” Dr. Bright
said, resigned.
“We’re all done here.”
For everyone else, it was just another failed
cross-test, quickly forgotten, with all the
others.
For SCP-049, it was one of the most traumatic
experiences of his life, one that would stay
with him forever, and be the reason he would
always be afraid of SCP-682.
Want an anomaly of your own?
Check out www.scpswag.com for high-quality
SCP merch!
Now go check out “Could SCP-682 be Contained
in the Backrooms?”
and “What did SCP-049 do During the Actual
Black Plague?”
for more stories of the Plague Doctor and
this nasty, nasty reptile!